what up guys welcome to morning coffee
thoughts
um today I want to talk about
how okay first of all if you wanna know
what happened in my face I know the
comments are going to be like what
happened last coffee thought video this
coffee thought video
um so
I want to talk about how the bigger you
get it almost gives people like more
ammo and it's really interesting how
certain people
um friends content creators whoever
supported me early on when I wasn't over
a certain point but then it's like you
get over a certain point and now
it's like the more you open up the more
they just like come for you for anything
for example
um this wife's school video I was so
nervous to put out I just put it and I
knew it would do well I knew people
would watch it and I knew like the
audience sector of like my audience
sector would like it but in it
I open up a lot and sometimes I talked
about
you know
maybe like struggles and dating I've had
or like and it's just the problem is
when you talk about issues you've had or
problems you've had or
um it gives the the opposite like the
the people that hate you or like want to
criticize you it just gives them more
ammo so it'll be like the people in the
in the red pill space that don't like me
they'll be like oh she's a grifter she's
just using her platform for attention
and then it's like the people that
don't like me like the feminists and
[ __ ] they'll be like see she's single
she can't talk about this she can't get
a man
and it's like the more you like open up
on the Internet the more people kind of
tear you apart
and
um
yeah it's just something I've learned
and I try not to let it like make me be
censored or anything but
um sometimes it's hard not to and it's
also you know you want to protect like
the your friends and your family because
sometimes y'all will
go after them it's like oh crazy some of
y'all okay
but I am really excited wife school got
50 000 54 000 views in two days and we
released it early you know uh
um I'm just I'm not I'm not gonna say
who said that we wouldn't do it I'm not
gonna say who not one 304 in episode one
nothing to do there will be an episode
with some 304 as modern women make it
funny nothing to do with that it's just
like I only got so much time to put
videos together and if there's like a
random day I can just go out it's just
easier for the main character to be me a
lot of [ __ ] was talked a lot of [ __ ] was
talked
um
that man should book me for a
consultation I'll show him how to
anyways anyways
um and wife school is free
sorry sorry sorry I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done
um but I want to talk about things that
we're looking for and if you're in the
U.S
um
or UK
um we're willing to travel to either or
um these are the the people that we
would like for a video so we would like
I'd like to do
um another fashion one with an actual
like professional stylist that can get
like clothes fitted and stuff and like a
color analysis like someone that's
really done it um
possibly like a dating coach that can
show you feminine ways to like approach
I don't know I don't know or like you
know be more feminine on dates and like
that sort of
ah see I I want to die thinking I'm
doing that video but I think I'm going
to I think I'm going to open up
I'll see okay
um and it doesn't mean that the dates
will be on video or anything you'll just
like talk about it before and after um
anyways third
um
third thing we're looking for
etiquette
um
as I showed last video I've been walking
with the book on my head
um Auntie's gonna help me with cooking
um but you never know if there's someone
else that wants to do cooking too
um
I'm trying to think of what else
oh makeup
two like feminine makeup
yeah let me those are the things that
I'm thinking of off the top of my head
but let me know if you guys can think of
some other stuff
um there's a woman in Florida that I
want to do a video with when I'm there
um
she she's like a homemaker she's like
this whole yeah but yeah that's and I
prefer
um honestly people for the the wives and
this is no disrespect I prefer to work
with wives that have no social media
presence because
um I've just found that foreign
if I don't know you personally I can't
really co-sign
there's a lot of bullshitters with the
wives on social media some of them are
legit but it's harder for me to tell if
you're just trying to I don't know it
the people that get what I'm saying get
it that's my preference not to say that
we can't do it but
um
yeah that's the
that's uh
all right
um
let me know what you guys think
um let me know what other episodes you
think we should have in wife's School
um
I really want to do etiquette I kind of
think like one episode at a time but I
gotta start putting the people together
um
but let me know what you guys think like
the video subscribe to the channel ring
that notification Bell I'll talk to you
next time